Peggy's 16 hey everyone it's Dan were
here with battlefield expert Stolley and
today we're going to give you a bit of a
guide to recommended weapons for the
assault and medic classes
first up we're going to look at the
assault class and specifically the light
infantry combat role so what gun have
you gone for and and why is that such a
good fit for that class so the light
infantry is a very aggressive assault
class so you want to go for a fast
firing fast reloading and good hipfire
assault weapon
so the Gewehr one five is perfect for
that as thirty one round it's got the
highest rate of fire for an assault
rifle in the game okay so let's let's
talk about specializations for this gun
talk me through these so you wanting to
go for the aim down your weapon sights
faster so that's quick aim it's
important for you to be able to acquire
targets quickly once you've spotted them
then you want to go for ported barrel
which means your weapon recoil is less
horizontally you're also going to want
to have improved accuracy and aimed fire
whilst moving so you can move left and
right and dodge other people's bullets
whilst you're aiming at them and then
finally the vertical recoil reduction so
on this specialization tree you've got
less vertical and less horizontal recoil
so you can really nail people at range
good stuff for sidearms you want to go
for a high damage sidearm so you want to
go for the revolver the rover does is a
two shot kill at close range so it means
if you run out of ammo and your main
assault rifle you can switch to your
revolver and maybe just hit them once
and they'll die straight away fantastic
and what about the gadgets side so the
gadgets side we're going for a standard
grenade because you're going to be
wanting to do as much damage to groups
of enemies as possible you're not really
using much utility and then you're gonna
go for the PIAT rocket launcher over the
Panzerfaust because the Panzerfaust is
more suited for destroying vehicles but
the PIAT launcher actually does really
high damage to infantry and then the
final thing I'd go for is the dynamite
so if you want to destroy the
fortifications you take the dynamite and
it's also amazing at lobbing edibles and
killing lots of infantry in a
so that's why you want you your
explosives I guess to cause that initial
damage and then rush in and make sure
that you've got that close-range combat
to enable you to get get those hits in
that's right and it's C just ready
extracting them with the explosives and
then you're running in with the rifle to
finish everyone off
okay so now let's talk about the the
vehicle buster weapon loadout what
skills are recommended pairing for this
one so for this one I've gone for the
stg44
it's quite similar to the Gewehr 1/5 but
it has a slower rate of fire and is
slightly more accurate over range so you
can do a little bit more tap firing you
can you can actually fight people at
longer ranges and I've gone for a medium
scope because it's actually the recoils
really controllable so even at close
range you can actually use the medium
scope and it shouldn't affect your aim
too much specializations it's one thing
to pick a weapon but what would you
recommend for that gun so for that gun
you're wanting to go for the
specializations that basically tone down
the recoil being able to do consecutive
shots is important with a gun like that
it's high damage over range so mainly
horizontal because horizontal recoil
harder to control that's what you want
to go for and then we're also seeing the
the anti-tank Bundle grenade that's
right so because you're not killing
infantry anymore you're trying to go for
the tanks the anti-tank grenade does a
significant amount of damage maybe
twenty to thirty percent of the tanks
health well then you also go for the
panzerfausts because it has less drop
you know what I mean it travels faster
than the PIAT reloads a little bit
quicker and does more damage and then
for the last equipment I went for the 80
mine because it's very passive and you
leave it on the ground you leave it
somewhere that has a high traffic of
vehicles and then the vehicles will
accidentally drive over them without
seeing them but you can also take the
sticky dynamite if you're if you want to
be a slightly more aggressive and you
can actually take out tanks on your own
just as the one assault class all of the
equipment is it is it a class that
benefits from maybe having a couple of
you working in tandem so you can really
sort of concentrate your you're firing
on two vehicles and I guess wear them
down much faster rather than you sort of
trying to fly solo
absolutely so because of your class as
soon as you damage that vehicle it'll
then spot it for all the other people on
the map so that your teammates who are
also playing assault can see where the
vehicle is and attack
from multiple angles
now we move over to the medic class
specifically the combat medic first your
weapon of choice for this is the suomi
with this class you want to be going for
hipfire weapons
so the suomi has a very good hipfire one
of the fastest rate of fires in the game
I've still gone for aiming down sight
33% faster I think that's very important
this one I've actually had to go for
more of the accuracy spec just to get
the extended mag the extended magazine
on this weapon is very important so you
start off with 30 rounds and with the
extended mag specialization that goes up
to 50 rounds and the reload speed is
roughly the same even with the extended
mag so you're running around at close
range spraying people with hipfire with
50 rounds it's devastating but as the
medic aspects lot into this
so with this class I've actually chosen
the medic bags so you can only throw out
one bag at a time but it means that you
can throw out bags whilst on the move so
you're going around fighting and whilst
fighting you can just be throwing medic
bags to your teammates and healing
yourself at the same time without having
to stop and put down a box I've also
chosen the revolver as the sidearm high
damage to shot kill at close range if
you happen to run out of ammo on your
suomi on your main weapon and then
there's also the grenade the normal frag
grenade again you're fighting infantry
at this point you're going for less of a
healing role but you can still revive
people heal people when it's appropriate
opportunistic almost got you so it's
really useful I guess sometimes if your
last man standing that you've got that
ability to to bring people back but
still still hold your own in the
meantime as well you know if you're
getting swamped yes
and lastly for this video let's talk
about the field medic combat role what's
it what's a good fit for this slightly
more passive role so um obviously you're
gonna be wanting to stay a bit more of a
distance you're not going to be wanting
to just rush in so I went for the slow
firing EMP is less reliant on hipfire
and it's a little bit more of a high
damage medium-range weapon so I've gone
for quick aim improved accuracy whilst
aiming in because I want to be mobile
whilst being accurate and then I've also
gone for some recoil reduction as well
I'm using the m1911 as a secondary
because it's more of a medium range
weapon with a few more rounds than the
revolvers so you can do a little bit
more damage more consistently at further
ranges with a faster reload I've also
gone for the incendiary grenade because
it's area-denial so it stops people from
being able to push so if you want to
revive your teammate and you don't want
the enemies to push through that doorway
you can throw that incendiary grenade at
last for five to ten seconds gives you
the time to revive people and and so
you've gone for a medical crate here
rather than throwing out packs so the
medical crate means that you leave it in
an area and multiple people can take as
many pouches as they want as long as the
medical crates there so it's much more
of a passive you know leave it with your
teammates and you can go and run off and
revive people and you can still be
healing them because they have to deal
with actually getting their own health
good stuff and here we see what's this
the smoke grenade rifle yep so this
one's really important when you're
reviving people out in the open if you
don't put a smoke grenade down they can
see you and shoot you whilst you're
reviving them but the smoke grenade
covers your actions and it just gives
you that cover so that people can't just
shoot you whilst you're reviving which
is a really common thing because you
have to take the two seconds to not be
able to look around you and the smoke
just guarantees that well thank you very
much study that's the end of our first
in-depth guide to the the weapons and
the combat roles of battlefield 5
look out for the next installment soon
well we'll be covering the weapons for
the support and recon classes thanks for
watching
plate on the world's most powerful
console
[Music]